[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركي
احييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
ساعتان ونصف على كتابه التاريخ رائد
الفضاء السعوديه
يتاهبان للانطلاق نحو محطه الفضاء الدولية
[موسيقى]
وصوره لابروف فوق اعلى نقاط مخموت وكياف
تهون وتؤكد ان مفاتيح المدينه في يدها
طرف الصراع في السودان ملتزمان باتفاق جده
وتحذير امامي لا تفوت الفرصه وحم المدنيين
لدينا ايضا
شرطي
واسع باقتحام غفير للاقصى ورام الله تطالب
بتدخل دولي وتؤكد ان خطه المتطرفين
[موسيقى]
يستعد رائد الفضاء السعوديان علي القرني
وريان برناوي للانطلاق في مهمتهما
التاريخيه الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه بعدما
يقرب من ساعتين من الان وستنطلق المركبه
التي ستقل علي وريانا من مركز كندي للفضاء
في جزيره مارت بولايه فلوريدا كان علي
القرني وريان برناوي دعا اهالهما قبل
الانتقال الى منطقه التجهيز كانا والدعاء
اهالهما قبل الانتقال الى منطقه التجهيز
للصعود على مركبه الاطلاق
اتمنى مؤخرا اجمال التدريبات المتعلقه
بالرحله
على كيفيه التعايش داخل المحطه الفضاء
الدوليه من اهداف الباحثين او العلماء
والمطورين اللي على الارض يجلبوا تجاربهم
هذه في الفضاء دوري الان هو اني امثل
المملكه في هذه المهمه العلميه بشكل عام
تثبت او او تمكننا من القدره على النجاح
في هذه المهمه وتعد هذه البعثات الفضائيه
هي احدى ثمار هذه الرؤيه ويوصل طموحنا
لعنان السماء
وفي لقاء خاص مع العربيه رائد الفضاء
السعوديان علي القرني وريان برناوي تحدث
حول التجارب والتدريبات والمهمه التاريخيه
ابرز الاشياء اللي خضعته لها حتى يتم
تاهيلكم بشكل كامل طبعا ولله الحمد اتمنى
مؤخرا اجمال التدريبات المتعلقه بالرحله
وكانت بشكل عام التدريب على المهام
اليوميه التشغيليه لمحطه الفضاء الدوليه
تدربنا على مركزين الابحاث الاوروبي
والياباني كذلك
التدريبات مجملتا على كيفيه التعايش داخل
المحطه الفضاء الدوليه وكذلك محاكاه
للانطلاق والعوده التدرب على الادوات اللي
بنستخدمها ان شاء الله في الابحاث العلميه
والابحاث
العمليه ان شاء الله على متن المحطه
فهذه التدريبات بشكل عام تثبت او او
تمكننا من القدره على النجاح في هذه
المهمه وكذلك بعد المهمه ان شاء الله نعود
الى ارض الوطن محققين جميع الاهداف
المرجوه من هذه الرحله
من جانبها وصفت رائده الفضاء ريان برناوي
في حديثها مع العربيه وصفت مشاعرها بعد
اختيارها ضمن المهمه العلميه الى الفضاء
لتصبح اول رائده فضاء عربيه ومسلمه تصل
الى الفضاء
اني اتذكر موقف كانه صار
لابسه الباط الباط حق المختبر حقي وخلاص
طالعه من البيت رايحه على دوامي
اتصال يعني فرديت طلع الاتصال من الهيئه
السعوديه للفضاء
فاول ما كلموني قالوا لي ريانه انت الان
صرتي اقرب للحلم مبروك تم اختيارك كاول
رائده فضاء سعوديه تذهب لمحطه الفضاء
الدوليه يعني الجمله لحالها خلاص يعني صرت
ماني عارفه دحين اروح الدوام ولا اخذ
اجازه ولا انا الان رائده فضاء او باحثه
ما صرت عارفه يعني كيف اتصرف انا بحكم
عملي في مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي انا
اسكن في الرياض واهلي في جده فاحد الاشخاص
اللي مهمين بالنسبه لي هي ستي ام الوالده
كنت حابه اني انا اقول لها الخبر وهي بجده
فطلعت على الغرفه جلست على السرير اتصلت
على العمل وطلب الاجازه واخذت تذكره من
الرياض لجده بس عشان ابلغها هذا الخبر
العظيم
من الرياض هاني صفيان مراسل العربيه اهلا
بك هاني يعني ما اخر المعلومات حول ما
يحصل الان قبيله الانطلاق
اهلا بك يا طاهر واهلا بمشاهدي قناه
العربيه مره اخرى من داخل مركز الموحد
لمهمه اطلاق رحله الفضاء والتي سوف تكون
على متن هذا الصاروخ وهو صاروخ او عبر هذا
الصاروخ فالكون طبعا راي دي الفضاء ريانه
علي صعداء الى هذا الصاروخ وتحديدا على
متن هذه الكبسوله كبسوله
دراغون او دراغون طبعا سوف نواكب او
مازلنا نواكب عمليه اطلاق الصاروخ ولكن
سوف يكون ضيفي قبل ان تتجول كاميرا
العربيه في مركز الموحد سوف يكون المهندس
ماجد المشاري وهو استشاري او المستشار هنا
في هيئه الفضاء مرحبا بك مهندس ماجد مرحبا
بك مره اخرى على شاشه العربيه يعني عندنا
باقي ساعتين ونصف تقريبا اللحظات هذه
دائما وبما انك انت سبق وانك حضرت في
مهمات اطلاق
لصاروخ لي مهمات سابقه
الاستعدادات دائما التي تقومون بعملها قبل
هذه المده طبعا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
اولا الوصول لهذه المرحله انجاز ولله
الحمد هذا يدل على انه جميع التجهيزات مره
الحمد لله على حسب ما هو مخطط عليه
اثناء مرحله العد التنازلي يتم تشغيل
المختلف اجزاء الصاروخ شيئا فشيئين
والتاكد من انها تعمل وفق ما هو مخطط لها
ولضمان سلامه الصاروخ وسلامه الاطلاق ايضا
يتم التاكد انه الظروف الجويه مواتيه
اليوم
الحمد لله انه الاجواء حتى الان مواتيه
باذن الله طيب يعني شاهدنا فرحه من ريانه
وعلي وكذلك الفضاء الاخرين يعني المعلومات
التي وصلتكم الان منوريدا ما هي اخر
التحديثات تقريبا الحمد لله جميع المؤشرات
تدل على ان رحله في موعدها المحدد
ونتمنى كل التوفيق لرواد الفضاء في هذا
المهمه طيب مهندس ماجد يعني سوف ننتقل الى
مرحله اخرى وبما اننا نتواجد في الرياض
وسوف نعود مره اخرى نتحدث عن هذا الصاروخ
هذا المركز هو مركز موحد وهو مركز انشاء
من اجل هذه المهمه يعني انا توقعت انه
هؤلاء فقط موظفين يتابعون عمليه الاطلاق
ولكن اكتشفت انه منهم من هو ومهندس من هو
مهتم بشان الفضاء منهم متخصصين في هذا
المجال معلومات وارقام يعني يتم من خلالهم
تدقيقها يعني في هذا الامر نعم الفريق
الموجود اليوم مهمته يعني
متابعه المعلومات وتحليلها وضمان ان
المهمه تجري وفقطت لها وايضا يعني يستفيد
وسائل الاعلاميه من الامكانات الموجوده في
في هذا المركز اللي نشروا المعلومه
الصحيحه ونشر الوعي يعني لع المهتمين في
هذه الحمله هناك تواصل بين الرياض
وفلوريدا من خلال مركز الموحد نعم هناك
تواصل مباشر لضمان انه المعلومات تاتي من
مصطرها الصحيح ونظام انها تنتشر لوسائل
الاعلام بالطريقه الصحيحه دكتور سعود لك
الى البحوث يعني يمكن ان نتكلم انا واياك
على البحوث العلميه عندنا 14 بحث علميا
سوف ينفذها ريان علي يعني هذه البحوث منها
الاستمطار ومنها ايضا بحوث الطبيه لو
نتكلم مجملها كيف سوف يتم ايضا التواصل او
الاتصال مع 12 الف طالب سوف يكونون على
ارض هم الذين قاموا باجراء هذه الاختبارات
قبل حملها من قبل ريان وعلي نعم بالنسبه
للتجارب التعليميه سيتم اجراؤها عبر 42
موقع حول المملكه بالتزامن بينهم وبين
المحطه الارضيه
ومقارنه النتائج لكل تجربه بينما هو على
الارض
حيث القوه الجاذبيه تؤثر على السوائل
وتؤثر على الديناميكيه الهواء وايضا تؤثر
على انتقال الحراره ومقارنتها بنتائج نفس
التجربه في نفس التوقيت التي تجري في محطه
الفضاء الدوليه والهدف من هذه التجارب هو
تقريب علوم الفضاء وبيئه الفضاء للطلاب
والمهتمين وربطها بالمفاهيم التي يدرسونها
في مقرراتهم الدراسيه الحاليه يعني هل
نتوقع اليوم من خلال التجارب يعني عند
السعوديه قامت يعني بحمل ريانه وعيد او
اعطاهم 14 بحث علمي هل يتوقع انه العدد
سوف يزيد خلال فتره قضائهم 12 يوما او هل
ممكن ان تنقص في هذا الامر بحسب الظروف
مثلا اولا هذه التجارب يعني تم التخطيط
لها وتصميمها وتنفيذها عبر فرق بحثيه
متعدده في المملكه ياتي على راس المراكز
او الفرق البحثيه الملك فيصل للتخصصي
ومركز الابحاث وايضا جامعه الملك فهد
للبترول والمعادن واحده من التجارب هذه
لاول مره تجرى في الفضاء وتتعلق بتطوير
تقنيات الاستمطار
حيث المخطط زياده فاعليه الاستمرار من 15%
الى اكثر من 50% وهذا اكثر من ثلاث اضعاف
ونتامل منها ان شاء الله تساهم في تحقيق
اهداف المملكه البيئيه خصوصا فيما يتعلق
بالسعوديه الخضراء والشرق الاوسط الاخضر
سوف اعود لك المهندس ماجد ولكن دعنا نلاحظ
هذه الصور الان التي تصلونه هنا تصلنا من
داخل المركز الموحد ونلاحظ هنا ريانه
وكذلك في الجهه الاخرى علي ونلاحظ ايضا
الاريحيه والسعاده وهنا يبدو انهم يحملان
بعض الكتيب او ما شابه كمبيوتر او بتعبث
في بيانات مثلا نعم كل كل رائد فضاء توكل
اليهم مهام
منها متابعه اداء الانظمه الموجوده سواء
في المحطه او في مركبه دراغون ويتم
التواصل مع المحطه الارضيه في حال يعني
احتياجهم الى
بيانات
ببعض البيانات لحماسه وكذلك الفرح
والسعاده يعني كانت واضحه على ريانه وعلي
يعني خاصه عنده صعودهم الى المصعد وتوجههم
الى الكبسوله هي لحظه فخر تاريخيه
للسعوديين جميعا انا حسيت بشعور عارم
صراحه لما اقتربوا من من المحطه وبداوا
يصعدون والان يعني اتوقع الساعتين ونص
القادمه هذي راح تكون طويله جدا علينا
يعني
لكنها لحظه فخر تاريخيه وشاهد ابتسامه
ريانه وشاهد الجميع يعني يعطي فمز اب
معناها وما شاء الله الرائد علي يصفق
وجاهز فهذه لحظات تاريخيه تخيل انك تروح
في رحله الفضاء اول رائده فضاء يعني
سعوديه عربيه مسلمه الى محطه الفضاء
الدوليه
لتجري تجارب هي كانت تعمل عليها لمده عشر
عشر سنوات في مسير ملك التخصصها يعني
نتكلم عن ريانه هي تحمل ماجستير في
الخلايا الجذعيه وكذلك علي هو طيار خريج
من كليه الملك فيصل الجويه وكان علامات
المقاتله اف 15 اس اي يعني تقريبا طار
اكثر من 2300 ساعه بالضبط
باتوقع بالنسبه لريانه راح تشوف بيئه
مختلفه كليا عن البيئه اللي تشوفها في
المختبر فراح تكون اقصايتد يعني يعني
متحمسه كثير انها تطبق هذه التجارب اللي
عملت عليها وراح تلاحظ الفرق بينها وبين
بيئه الارض ما شاء الله الرائد علي القرني
بحكم انه الطيار متعود على المناورات
متعود على يعني
هذه راح تكون نقله ثانيه في يعني حياه
المهنيه ان يكون علامات صاروخ طبعا هو
متعود اكثر اتوقع من غير
الطيارين انها راح تكون نقله كبيره في
حياه المهنيه باذن الله شكرا لك مهندس
ماجد اذا هذا كان حديث المهندس ماجد
المشاري وهو المستشار هنا في هيئه
الاتصالات والفضاء والتقنيه ونحن ايضا
نتواجد هنا في مركز الموحد ونلتقط هذه
الصور اذا في اللوحه الاخرى تبقى لنا
ساعتين واثنا وعشرين دقيقه والثواني تنقص
وتتجه الى الدقيقه 21 بينما ايضا هنا في
مركز الموحد ومنسوبي والمهندسين وكذلك
التقنيين والمهتمين ايضا وهم من شانهم
تحليل هذه المعلومات وتحليل هذه البيانات
التي يراقب يراقبونها في هذه اللحظات
لحظات الساعات
الساعتين المتبقيتين وهم يراقبون لحظه
اطلاق الصاروخ او لحظه انطلاق الصاروخ
بينما نشاهد لو ياتي المصور قليلا ونلاحظ
هنا بعض البيانات وايضا بعض التحليل الذي
يقوم بها هذا المهندس بالتعرف على الشكل
الاخير
على هذه الكبسوله وكذلك من داخل ايضا
فلوريدا وايضا المسار الذي سوف يسير به
الصاروخ ولا يختلف الامر كثيرا بالنسبه
ايضا لهؤلاء الشباب وكذلك الشابات في
الجهه الاخرى
هاني صفايان شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه
التفاصيل من داخل المركز الموحد ولنا عوده
اليك طبعا في متابعتنا لحظه بلحظه
لساعات ما قبل الانطلاق
طريق صعب وشاق ينتظر ايدي الفضاء
السعوديين علي وريان الزميل نايف الاحمري
يعطينا عرضا افتراضيا عن الرحله كيف تبدا
متى تنتهي بتقنيه الواقع المعسس
هذا ليس صاروخا يستخدم في حروب العصر
الحديث انه تالكون تسعه ذلك الصاروخ الذي
ينقلنا الى ابعد رحلات استكشافيه في الكون
وربما في اهم رحلات التنقيب عن اسرار
الفضاء وحل الغاز هذا الصاروخ مشاهدينا
تلتصق فيه مركبه دراغون التي نراها هنا
سيكون علمتني دراغون اول امراه سعوديه
تحلق نحو الفضاء ريان برناوي وعلي القرني
رائد الفضاء السعودي يقومان برحله الى
فضاء الخارجي لزياره محطه الفضاء الدوليه
رفقه اثنين اخرين ضمن مهمتي
وهذه اول رحله صعود الى الفضاء لفريق رواد
سعوديين لتدشن المملكه عصرا جديدا في
استكشاف الفضاء وعلامه فارقه للحدث
التاريخي تعالوا معنا مشاهدينا لنصعد الى
الفضاء افتراضيا طبعا لكن حذاري انها ليست
كاي رحله الوصول الى الفضاء وحده يستغرق
نحو 24 ساعه قبل التحليق لابد لرواد
الفضاء من المرور بمراحل عده وتدريبات
مكثفه واختبارات حاسمه وهذا ما مر به علي
وريان بالطبع حيث خضع لكافه البرامج
التدريبيه التي تساعدهما على اتمام هذه
المهمه بنجاح واجراء التجارب العلميه
المتعلقه برحلتهما الى الفضاء تبدا الرحله
فعليا مشاهدينا بالصعود على متن مركبه
دراغون اول مركبه فضائيه خاصه تنقل البشره
الى المحطه الفضائيه تصل حموله المركبه
الى اربعه ركاب من والى المدار نشاهد
الركاب هنا في استديو العربيه لكنها قادره
مشاهدينا ايضا على اعاده كميات كبيره من
الحملات الى الارض لنستعد اذا لمرحله
الاطلاق
بعد انطلاقه من المنصه يصل الصاروخ لسرعه
الصوت ولا ننسى مشاهدينا ان الصاروخ يمر
باعلى منطقه ضغط هوائي ديناميكي
وبالارتفاع 80 كيلو مترا تتم عمليه
الانفصال الاول بعد سبع دقائق وحين يصل
لمدار الارض المنخفض يتم الانفصال الثاني
بعد ذلك ترتبط مركبه دراغون بمحطه الفضاء
الدوليه هذه هي محطه الفضاء الدوليه في
هذه المرحله مشاهدينا يقوم الطاقه بمركبه
دراغون بعمل مناوره باستخدام الدافعات حتى
يتم الاقتراب والالتحام بالمحطه
ها قد وصلنا مشاهدينا اذا الى المحطه في
هذه الرحله سيجري رواد الفضاء السعوديون
14 تجربه رائده في الجاذبيه الصغرى بما
فيها تجارب توعويه تعليميه يشارك فيها 12
الف طال ب وطالبه واثنان واربعون موقعا في
السعوديه عبر الاقمار الصناعيه مهمات
كثيره ولافته بانتظار علي وريان في الفضاء
ونحن هنا على الارض ننتظر عودتهما من
الفضاء سالمين
ان شاء الله معنا من فلوريد الان نراسل
العربيه حسين اهلا بك مره جديده كيف ترقب
فلوريدا الانطلاق
طاهر بعد اللحظات الحماسيه التي عشناها
عندما وصل رواد الفضاء الى هذا المركز
واستقبلناهم ولوحوا لنا وودعوا اهاليهم
بعد ما لوحوا لهم طبعا الان نعيش لحظات
ترقب في انتظار انطلاق الصاروخ نحن على
بعد ساعتين وسبعه عشر دقيقه لنبالغ ايضا
ان قلنا ان هاتين الساعتين ربما هما
الاطول بالنسبه لعلي وريان قبل انطلاقهما
الى الفضاء الرحله من من فلوريدا من هنا
من
مركز كندي للفضاء الى المحطه الفضائيه
ستستغرق سته عشر ساعه حتى تلتحم المركبه
الفضائيه دراغون بالمحطه الفضائيه الدوليه
وهنا لابد من التذكير مره اخرى بين هذه
المركبه هي اول مركبه خاصه تنقل البشر الى
المحطه الفضائيه وهي تسير بحسب ما فهمنا
من موظفي اكسيوم هي تقود نفسها بنفسها
اوتوماتيكيا تلقائيا اما بالنسبه لرايدي
الفضاء الامريكيين فهما قد يتداخلان اذا
كان هناك اي طارئ لتصحيح مسار هذه المركبه
كما ذكر العداد اللي وراك ونعلم بان
الردان عندما يدخلان الى المحطه
نعم امامي هكذا
نعم هناك هناك ساعتين و16 دقيقه قبل ان
تنطلق
ربما نعم نعم قبل ان تنطلق ينطلق هذا
الصاروخ
احضرنا مع
في تاخير لانه بوصول الصوت
صحيح
كما قلنا
هذه المهمه ستبقى في الفضاء لمده عشره
ايام ثمانيه ايام منهم سيقضين سيقضين منها
ريان وعلي سيقضيانها داخل المحطه لاجراء
14 تجربه علميه تتعلق بالجاذبيه
تتعلق بالجاذبيه
وتاثير الجاذبيه على
الاعضاء البشريه بعد بعد ذلك طبعا بعد
عشره ثمانيه ايام او عشره ايام من الان
ستعود هذه الرحله الى الارض طبعا هناك
طبعا ايضا خطوات لكي تعود ستستغرق ما بين
سته الى 30 ساعه على حسب موقع المحطه
الدوليه انذاك انا تحدثت قبل قليل الى عدد
من موظفي اكسيوم الذين تعاملوا مع علي ومع
ريان وحدثاني
عنهما وعن طبيعتهما قالوا انهم متحمسون
للتعامل مع هذين الرائدين لما اظهراه من
حماسه ومن علمي ومن من
طموح لدى هذين ويعتبرون انهما سيقولان
قدوه للشباب السعودي والشباب العربي
وسيحفزون الشباب السعودي وحتى الاجيال
القادمه على الاهتمام اكثر بها علوم
الفضاء وهذا هو احد اهداف الهيئه السعوديه
للفضاء بان تكون هذه باكوره الرحلات
الفضائيه الى المحطه الدوليه والى الفضاء
وهنا يجب ان نذكر بان الهيئه وقعت على
اتفاقيه واحد
للاستفاده واستكشاف
القمر والمريخ والكبات وايضا من اجل عوده
الانسان الى القمر اذا هو برنامج سعودي
طموح لحظات تاريخيه توثق لبدء الرحلات
الفضائيه تحدث مع مدير المكتبه التكنولوجي
في اكسيوم سالته هل هناك رحلات اخرى قريبه
قال لي نعم هناك رحلات اخرى تساهم
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ستكون في
المستقبل من خلال هيئه الفضاء السعوديه
حدثني عن دول عربيه اخرى قد تساهم في هذه
الرحلات اذا نحن امام عصر فضائي عربي اذا
صح التعبير تقوده الان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه تساهم بشكل فعال بشكل كبير هنا
لابد من التفكير بان ريانه هي اول امراه
عربيه وسعوديه تكون رائده فضاء وتصعد الى
الفضاء الى الفضاء الخارجي وتذهب الى
المحطه الدوليه الاجواء هنا هناك كما قلنا
هناك ترقب هناك وفود اعلاميه من المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وحتى اهتمام اعلامي
امريكي بهذه المهمه
تم تسطيط الضوء على موضوع ان الريانه هي
اول امراه عربيه
ستكون رائده فضاء هذه
الرحله هذه الماما ايضا من اولى المهمات
التي تكون هناك مشاركه ما بين ناسا ومن
بين شركه خاصه لذلك هناك اهتمامات اهتمام
كبير بها اعلاميا وايضا على المستوى
الرسمي عظيم شكرا جزيلا لكم مراسل العربيه
حسين فلوريدا وسنكون في عوده اليك لاحقا
حتى موعد الاطلاق تغطيه مستمره
[موسيقى]
باقونا معكم من متابعه ايضا في العربيه
360 في لهجه غير معتاده بايدن يقول ان
العلاقات مع الصين ستشهد تحسنا كبيرا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى ملف الحرب
الاوكرانيه والتي ما تزال ضخمه تمثل فيها
الجائزه الكبرى في هذه المرحله المعقده من
الصراع هكذا اذاعه مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه
الخاصه خبر سيطرتها على بخموت فيديو لعنصر
من عناصرها يرفع علم المجموعه على احد
مباني المدينه وعلى خدته صوره وزير
الخارجيه الروسي
وعباره تحمل معنى هكذا تكون التسويه مع
الاغبياء في اشاره طبعا لاوكرانيا وربما
من يدعمها ايضا يبدو ان النصر الذي اعلنته
فاجنر سيصلح سيصلح الكثير من العلاقات في
المعسكر الروسي فاجنر اكدت ان الجيش
الروسي لعب دورا في السيطره على المديء
بالفعل القوات الجويه الاستراتيجيه
والقوات الصاروخيه بعيده المدى دعمتنا عده
مرات خلال عمليه تحرير ضخمه بالنسبه
للوحدات الروسيه المقاتله فقد تم تسليمنا
اللواء المدفعيه رقم 305 لتعمل تحت امره
قياده المدفعيه الخاصه بنا وقد تم تدريبهم
وابلوا بلاء حسنا ايضا على احد الاجنحه
عمل اللواء رقم 57 بشكل مقبول اثناء تحرير
باباسنايا كانت تعمل معنا الوحده رقم 40
من قوات المشاه البحريه التابعه لاصول
المحيط الهادي وكانوا على قدر المسؤوليه
فيما يخص باقي المجموعات وحول مساعده قوات
الانزال لنا فهذا كلام فارغ عندما كانوا
يجرون انزالا معينا كنا نحن نساعدهم واريد
ان اؤكد على هذا الامر ان ما يتعلق
بالجنود فهم ابطال حقيقيون ولكن
لديهم قاده مشلولون بشكل كامل
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين دخل على
الخط وهنئ قوات فاغنر والجيش الروسي بعد
اعلان السيطره على مدينه بخموت واصدر
بوتين توجيهاته برفع اسماء ابطال العمليه
المتميزين لتقليدهم اوصمه الشرف التي
استحقوها الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت في وقت
سابق انه تمت السيطره على مخموت نتيجه
للعمليات الهجوميه لوحدات فاجنر وبدعم من
طيران ومدفعيه الجيش
في المقابل بدا رئيس الاوكراني وكانه
تراجع عن تصريحات فسرت على انها تحمل
اعترافا منه بخساره المدينه اذ اكد ان
القوات الاوكرانيه ما تزال هناك
اليوم يقومون بمهمه بالغه الاهميه وهم في
باخموت حتى اليوم ولكن لن اخبرك في اي
موقع بالضبط لكن هذا يعني ان بخموت لم يتم
احتلالها من قبل الاتحاد الروسي
ومره اخرى عدم مؤسس فاجنر ليرد على ويؤكد
انه لم يبقى في بخموت اي جندي اوكراني
لم يبقى في بخموت اي جندي اوكراني لاننا
لا نجد من يمكننا اخذه في الاسر وهناك عدد
كبير من جثث الجيش الاوكراني زيلينسكيماكر
اوليس على علم بما يحدث على الارض
اما عسكريا فتفسر كيا بالوضع في باخمه
بشكل مختلف الجنرال الاوكرانيه
اكد ان القوات الاوكرانيه تسيطر على جزء
ضئيل شرق بخموت سيمكنها من دخول المدينه
عندما يتغير الوضع وان ما حدث كان تكتيكا
لتطويق المدينه
اذا بعد ثمانيه اشهر من المعارك الطاحنه
يبدو الوضع وكان المواقع تتبدل بين من
سيطر على المدينه ومن يحاصرها قوات فاجنر
اعلنت انها استحوذت على المدينه بالكامل
على ان تسلمها للجيش الروسي يوم الخميس
وفق تقرير لنيويورك تايمز وعلى مدار
اسابيع ابتكر الجنود الاوكرانيون
استراتيجيه للهجوم اثناء تبديل المناوبه
بين وحدات عناصر فاجنر وهو توقيت يمثل
نقطه ضعف كبيره للمجموعه العسكريه وللحفاظ
على عنصر المفاجاه اعتمد الاوكرانيون على
الهجوم عبر الجنود المشاه بينما اقتصر
استخدام المدفعيه على التلال والمرتفعات
التي تسيطر عليها القوات الاوكرانيه لقصف
قوات فاجنر هذه الاستراتيجيه مكنت
اوكرانيا من استعاده قطعه ارض بعرض ثلاثه
كيلومترات جنوب قريه ايفاني شرقا او خارج
مساحه قد تبدو صغيره الا ان الاوكرانيين
اعتمدوا على نجاحهم واستعادوا اكثر من 20
كيلومترا مربعا شمال وجنوب وفقا للجيش هذه
المكاسب الاوكرانيه تمثل ضربه محتمله
لجهود الحربيه الروسيه التي جعلت من بخ
مونتاج جائزه الاستراتيجيه الاساسيه لها
وعلى جانب الاوكراني فان استعاده هذه
الاراضي قد يساعد كياف او تساعد كياف في
الوقت الذي تتاهب فيه لهجومها المضاد من
خلال اضعاف القوات الروسيه في عده نقاط
على طول الجبهه ايضا اشارت نيويورك تايمز
الى ان اوكرانيا تستغل الانقسامات العلنيه
بين الافرع المسلحه الروسيه من جيش وقوات
فاجنر وقوات شيشانيه لتحقيق تقدم على
الارض وان كان محدودا نسبيا الجيش
الاوكراني قال ان عشرات الاشتباكات تدور
كل يوم في المنطقه وان جنوده سيواصلون
محاوله التقدم بشكل مستمر يفهم من هذا
الكلام ان بخنوت لا تزال غير محسومه
بالكامل لكن كان الاوكرانيون داخلها اما
الان فتغير الوضع بناء على التصريحات
الروسيه وبات الروس في الداخل معنى من عضو
البرلمان الاوكراني كيرا رودريغ اهلا بك
معنا
اريد ان اعرف منك اي دلائل تعتمد عليها
القياده الاوكرانيه في نفي الاعلانات
الروسيه عن السيطره الكامله على مخ
شكرا على صداقتي اولا دعني اذكركم
انه
مره سبعه او ثمانيه مرات على ادعاءات
روسيا في سيطرتها على باتموت
والجانب الاوكراني يثق بقواته العسكريه
وفي الصحفيين الدوليين الذين سوف يكونوا
بمقدورهم النفي او تاكيد تلك التصريحات
لكن بالنسبه للجانب الروسي لا يوجد اي
صحفيين لتاكيد ما يصدر عنهم من بيانات ان
قواتنا العسكريه
تقدم تلك التصريحات بناء على ما يرونه على
الارض وفي مناطق محدده من بخمد
وهذا يدفع يدفعنا انطلاقا من المنطقه الذي
تحمله تلك البيانات ان نصدقها
ونتذكر ان روسيا منذ الخليفه الماضي لم
تحقق اي نصره اي نصره للبتل لذا لابد لها
ان تظهر تحقيق اي نصر لشعبها وخاصه من
خلال الزياره الاخيره التي قام بها الى
مجموعه دول السبع وجامعه الدول العربيه
ولكن هناك تصريحات اوكرانيه رئاسيه فهم
منها انها اعتراف ومن ثم تراجع اضافه الى
ان الجيش الاوكراني لو كان
يسيطر فعلا لكان بامكانه تقديم بعض ادله
العسكريه على اماكن تواجده على المناطق
التي يتواجد بها وعلى الكثير من البراهين
التي يمكن ان يقدمها ليرد على الجانب
الروسي الذي يبدو مجمعا هذه المره
بجيشها وبقوات الفاغنر وقوات الشيشانيه
على هذا الكلام بعد الخلافات التي عصفت
بينهم
هذه ليست للمره الاولى التي تزعم فيها
روسيا بانها سيطرت على بخمه ولكننا نحن لا
نرد
حول تغطيه مواقع قواتنا
لتسريبها للقوات الروسيه تذكروا انهم
قالوا بانهم سيطروا عليك بانهم سوف
يسيطرون على كيف خلال ثلاثه ايام
والبلاد برمتها خلال اسابيع هذه كلها
تصريحات غير حقيقيه حول النصر
وتجافي الصواب لذا
لابد لنا ان ننتظر يوم او اثنين
لنعرف كيف سوف تتجلى الصوره بشكلها
الحقيقي حتى اللحظه لم نسمع اي تصريحات من
قبل الجانب الاوكراني
بشان مساله فوزي القوات مجموعه
احتلالها
لباخمت بالكامل خلال اليومين القادمين سوف
نرى بان روسيا تقوم بتضليل بشن حمله تظليل
المعلومات وهذا جزء من التي اتبعتها في
العدم ما من قصص النجاحات للجيش الروسي في
اي مكان اخر وليس وتفتقر الى اي نجاحات
على مر الاشهر السبع او ثمانيه الماضيه
وكان جنودها يموتون باعداد كبيره دون اي
سبب فقط لسبب واحد وهو تدمير بلادنا شكرا
جزيلا لك يعض البرلمان الاوكرانيه
خلال مشاركته في قمه السابعه استدعى
الرئيس الاوكراني تاريخ
ليضيء على الوضع في مدينه باخمت
الاوكرانيه ما استدعى هذالنسكي هو وضع
مدينه هيروشيما بعد قصفها بالقنبله الذريه
لكن ليس كل التاريخ في صالحه
يقارن باخموت بهيروشيما مدينتان تعرضتا
للتدمير وضعت ملامحهما
وهيروشيما لكن الزائر الاخيره حاول الربط
بينهما
[موسيقى]
استطيع القول بصراحه ان صور هيروشيما
المدمره تذكرني بباخمت وغيرها من المدن
المماثله لا يوجد شيء على الاطلاق تم
تدمير جميع المباني لا يمكن حتى ادراك
اماكن الشوارع والمباني هذا دمار كامل
مطلق لا يوجد شيء ولا يوجد بشر
هيروشيما قصفت بقنبله ذريه في السادس من
اغسطس عام
1945 قتل فيها 140 الفا نصفهم مباشره
والنصف الاخر جراء الاثار النوويه
ضخمه الاوكرانيه رزحت لاشهر تحت قتال
دمرها بالكامل تقريبا كان فيها 70 الف
نسمه فرو وتحولت المدينه لمنطقه عسكريه
مغلقه عدد قتلى باخموت يتوقع ان يتجاوز
عدد سكانها قبل القتال زيلينسكي طالب
بالحساب عما حدث في باخموت لكن فاته ان
هيروشيما كذلك لم تعرف طريقا للقصص
[موسيقى]
توالت الادانات العربيه والاقليميه
الاقتحام وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
للمسجد الاقصى في القدس الخارجيه السعوديه
اكدت في بيان لها ان القوات الاسرائيليه
مسؤوله عن تداعيات استمرار التجاوز على
المسجد الاقصى وادانت عمليات الاقتحام كما
دعت الامارات تل ابيب لوقف التصعيد ومنع
رفع التوتر في المنطقه وشدد الامين العام
لمجلس التعاون الخارجي جاسم البداوي على
ضروره وقف الانتهاكات وحملا اسرائيل
مسؤوليه اي ردود فعل ناجمه عنها اما
الخارجيه المصريه فقد وصفت الاقتحام
بالتصرف الاستفزازي وهو عكس ما يجب ان
يتحلى به المسؤولون الرسميون الخارجيه
الاردنيه اعتبرت ان اقتحام المسجد الاقصى
خطوه استفزازيه مدانه تمثل خرقا فاضحا
ومرفودا للقانون الدولي
كانت رئاسه الفلسطينيه دانت خطوه الاقتحام
الاسرائيليه وقال الناطق الرسمي باسم
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه نبيل ابو ردينا ان
اقتحام لساحات الاقصى للمره الثانيه
اعتداء سافر سيكون له تداعيات خطيره مشددا
على ان محاولاتير وامثاله من المتطرفين
لتغيير الوضع القائم في المسجد الاقصى
مدانه ومرفوضه وستبوء بالفشل كما دعا
بوردينا المجتمع الدولي وخاصه الاداره
الامريكيه للتحرك الفوري
هذا وعقدت الحكومه الاسرائيليه اجتماعها
الاسبوعي اليوم في الانفاق الواقعه اسفل
المسجد الاقصى في مدينه القدس وذلك ضمن
مساعي المصادقه على مشاريع تهويديه
للمدينه وعلى راسها ما يسمى مشروع الحوض
المقدس
من الناصره الكاتب والمحلل السياسي وديعه
اهلا بك معنا استاذ وديع لماذا يقدم
نتنياهو وحكومته على مثل هذه الافعال بهذه
الطريقه في هذا التوقيت ما الذي يحاول ان
يصل اليه
اولا كانت هناك مناسبه اسرائيليه وهي
توحيد القدس الشطرنج القدس المحتله ما
يعرف بهم القدس الذكرى السادسه والخمسين
هذه المره اختارنا ان يفعل ذلك من خلال
الاجتماع للمجلس الحكومي في نفق اسفل
المسجد الاقصى ولذلك هناك سؤال وجيه لماذا
الان ولماذا هناك عن المكان والزمان طبعا
هناك يعني دلاله لذلك
نتنياهو طالما كان منذ ان صعد سدت الحكم
في العام 1996 يدفع باتجاه منع تسويه
الدولتين
وتكريس واقع الاحتلال في القدس في شطريها
الغربي والشرقي وهو يعني بتوجهاته
الايديولوجيه كان منذ ان انطلق هو بهذا
الخط الان هو يعني فعل من خلال هذا
التوقيت بالذات ومن خلال دفع اجتماع حكومي
للمره الاولى في داخل نفق هو اراد ان يرسل
رسائل بالاساس سياسيه داخلي
وان هناك اجتماع او يعني الكنيست سينتهن
بعد يومين للمصادقه على الموازنه العامه
وهناك تصويت تقليدي في اسرائيل انفشل
سيعتبر ذلك نزع ثقه من الحكومه وستسقط
الحكومه وهناك اوساط او احزاب وبالذات
حسبان حسب
وهو حزب القوى اليهوديه العظم اليهوديه
وحزب اخر حزب
يهددان بعدم التصويت وبالتالي هذا يؤدي
الى حاله فوضى سياسيه
ونتنياهو طبعا هناك طلبات ماليه عشيره
المصادق على هذا الميزانيه نتنياهو في هذا
الموقف اراد ان يمارس الضغوط بالترهيب
والترغيب على شركائه في الائتلاف الحاكم
وكانه يقول ان المعركه مفتوحه على القدس
ولا لم تنتهي انتبهوا اياكم وان تلعبوا
بالنار وان تسكتوا هذه الحكومه بسبب
خلافات داخليه او خلافات على ميزانيات هذا
بالنسبه الى الرسائل الداخليه وهذا مهم
جدا هل توافق على انه نتنياهو يحاول ان
يمرر رسائل الى الخارج ايضا خاصه الى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه للضغط عليها
للقائه
نحن نؤكد موقف الايديولوجي من وحده هذه
المدينه المحتله استاذ شكرا جزيلا لك على
هذه القراءه
السياسي من الناصره تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
رحبت الامم المتحده باعلان وقف اطلاق
النار المؤقت في السودان
وقالوا الامين العام للامم المتحده لشؤون
الانسانيه ان على الاطراف المتحاربه
السماح بايصال المساعدات بطريقه امنه
واضاف ان الامم المتحده ستواصل مع شركائها
القيام بكل ما في وسعها لتقديم المساعدات
كان الجيش السوداني اكد ان اتفاق الهدنه
الذي جرى التوافق عليه بجده ينحصر فقط في
الجوانب العسكريه والفنيه ولا يتضمن
المسائل السياسيه واوضح ان الاتفاق يشمل
وقف اطلاق النار المؤقت واجراءات حريه
تنقل المدنيين اضافه الى حمايتهم واخلاء
المستشفيات وصيانه مرافق الخدمات
من جهتها رحبت قوات الدعم السريع باتفاق
جده والترتيبات الانسانيه لتسهيل وصول
المساعدات واكدت انها ستلتزم بوقف اطلاق
النار بدءا من مسائل الغد وانها ستعمل على
تسهيل ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه وفتح
الممرات للمدنيين
تستمر لاخر لحظه لا ندم لسياد اتفق معه
خسران فيها الشعب السوداني هو اللي بيدفع
ثمنه والله الاتفاق ان شاء الله يعني اسمي
بهدنه حقيقيه وتسلم ارواح الناس يعني
الشعب السوداني صبر صبر صبر في النهايه
بيقتل يعني اطفال نساء عجايز يعني الناس
بتموت في الشوارع بدون اي ذنب
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان العلاقات
بين واشنطن ستشهد تحسنا كبيرا واضاف
بايدينا ان امريكا لا تريد صداما مع الصين
بل تريد تنويع وتوجيه علاقاتها معها وقال
ان واشنطن لا تسعى لقطع العلاقات مع بكين
وانما لتقليل المخاطر
وفي العربيه 360 ايضا
العبقري جاء بوعد لتغيير ناديه فغيرت
التاريخ في مانشستر
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد للذكاء الاصطناعي القدره
على اعاده تشكيل مستقبل التعليم ويتطلب
استخدامه في التعليم تقييما مدروسا انواع
عده لروبوتات الدردشه والتطبيقاتها تتراوح
بين كتابه رسائل بريد الكتروني احترافيه
وحتى كتابه اوراق بحثيه كامله وغير ذلك
وتنتاب المعلمين وايضا ارباب العمل مخاوف
تتعلق بنزاهه العمل او الدراسه اذ
باستطاعه الذكاء الاصطناعي التغلب على
الحدود للوصول الى تعليم بلا قيود الا انه
على الجانب الاخر له تاثيرات سلبيه
صحيفه البريطانيه نشرت تحقيقا حول نواحي
سلبيه للذكاء الاصطناعي في المجال
التعليمي ببريطانيا التقت صحيفه بيطالب
يبلغ من العمر 16 عاما استعان بمساعده
زميل دراسه الجديد بالذكاء الاصطناعي عبر
هذه المساعده تمكن من انشاء بحث مصغر حول
حياه مصممه بريطانيه وكانت بعض المعلومات
الوارده في البحث غير مذكوره في اي مكان
على الانترنت استطلاع اخر اجرته صحيفه
فارسيتي الطلابيه بجامعه كيمبردج الشهر
الماضي اظهر ان ما يقرب من نصف الطلاب قد
استخدموا تشات جي بي تي لاكمال دراستهم
20% من الطلاب استعانوا بهذه الاداه
للحصول على درجاتهم العلميه بينما خطط
السبعه في المئه لاستخدامها في الاختبارات
للغش في سويسرا كشف معهد روزنبرغ سويسري
عن ان الثلاثين في المئه من الدرجات في
المعهد تم الحصول عليها باستخدام الذكاء
الاصطناعي ورغم السلبيات يصعب ترجيح كفتها
على الايجابيات بحسب تقرير فاينانشيل
تايمز رغم انه يصعب ذلك لكن الصحيفه طرح
التساؤلا حول ما اذا كان من الممكن فتح
الباب امام الذكاء الاصطناعي في التعليم
دون المساس باهم ميزات التعلم البشري
[موسيقى]
الى تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 الرئيسه
سلومي زورا شخص غير مرغوب فيه وستحضر من
استخدام الخطوط الجويه الجورجيه حتى تعتذر
امام الشعب التصريح هو لمؤسس الخطوط
الجويه الجورجيه وهي شركه ذات ملكيه خاصه
بعد ان دعت الرئيس للتصدي لخطط الشركه
لاستئناف الرحلات الجويه مع روسيا واعلنت
مقاطعتها للشركه تدافع الرئيس عن خطط
الاوروبيه في مقاطعه روسيا بينما يدافع
المسؤول الجورجي عن حقوق مواطنيه في
التنقل الى اي وجهه يريدونها اما الرابح
الاكبر بين كل هذا فهو بالتاكيد موسكو
فيديو اليوم من تونس كعادتها كل عام تنتظر
داود ازهار الربيع لتبدا في ممارسه شغفها
الخاص انتاج ماء الازهار تفضل داود طريقه
الاولين في مهنتها تقطف الازهار بيديها
ازهار البرتقال والياسمين وغيرها توقد
الحطب وتغلي الورود تغليها في الماء ثم
تقطر بخار هذا المزيج لتحصل على ماء
الازهار لم تفكر داود في طرق اكثر حداثه
لانها تؤمن بان الشغف في كل خطوه هو ما
يجعل ماء زهرها اكثر جوده حتى ولو تخطت
الستين وحتى لو زاد التعب فما تفعله امانه
فما تفعله امانه حملتها من الام
ومن ام الام
صوره اليوم في محيط ملعب الاتحاد صارت
صورته ايقونه لجماهير مانشستر سيتي فقبله
كانت المنافسه بين الكبار معروفه مانشستر
يونايتد تشيلسي ليفربول ارسنال الكل يلعب
على المركز الاول اما من بعده فصارت
المنافسه فقط على المركز الثاني
المجنون غزير الافكار معقد الخطط احرز
لقبا جديدا في اكثر الدوريات تنافسيه في
العالم لقبه الخامس في سته مواسم متى
يملك في سجل مانشستر سيتي خمسه القاب
للدوري الانجليزي من اصل 9
والى ميسون
وتتابع معكم في اخبار الساعه وتركيز ايضا
وايضا على اطلاق المهمه هذا اليوم تاريخي
السعودي على اطلاق الرائدين الفضاء
السعوديين الى مركبه الفضاء الدوليه ميسون
مساء الخير طبعا هذا هو الملف الاول الكل
يترقب والكل عيونهم شاخصه الان على
فلوريدات بانتظار انطلاق على القرنه
وريانه برناوي الى الفضاء في هذا اليوم
التاريخي بالنسبه للدول العربيه وخاصه
بالنسبه للسعوديه التي تركز على استكشاف
الفضاء من خلال هذين الرائدين اليك تفضلي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات